okay today I'm going to talk to you
about sexual reproduction reproduction
is all about making more members of a
particular species and sexual
reproduction produces genetically
different offspring so offspring that
are different to each other so in humans
and in lots of other organisms as well
we have the idea of these two things
called gametes now all that the word
gamete means is it's the scientific term
for a sex cell so a scientific term do
with a cell to do with sexual
reproduction so obviously the two
gametes are sperm cells these are
produced in the testes of men and egg
cells these are released from the
ovaries of women now within each of
these gametes we have a nucleus the
nucleus is where the chromosomes are
stored all that a chromosome is is a big
store of DNA so there's the chromosomes
with the DNA from the dad and those the
chromosomes are the DNA from the mum now
both of these gametes are said to be
haploid now what that means is haploid
have half the full number of chromosomes
compared to the rest all of the other
cells within the organism and we'll see
why that is in a minute so during sexual
after sexual intercourse there'll be a
point where these two meats actually
meet in the duct and they fuse together
they fuse and join together and that
fusion together is called fertilization
so fertilization is the joining is the
fusing together of the sperm cell and
the egg cell now actually I've got to be
too misleading if I was to do these in a
kind of better scale the egg cell is
much much bigger than a sperm cell I
just wanted to draw them both the same
size so you can see the structure of
them so they've join it together fusing
together is called fertilization now
once they fuse together
we forum we have this fertilized egg
cell which is formed and that's got a
special name it's called a zygote
so this zygote just means fertilized egg
cell if we were to look inside the
nucleus of the zygote we can see that we
have chromosomes from the sperm cell so
from the dad and chromosomes from the
egg cell from the mum now this number
now we have these these these two nuclei
fuse together join together we've
combined all of these all of these
chromosomes together so we now have the
diploid number of chromosomes that just
means the full amount for any normal
cell so in humans the haploid number is
23 so 23 pairs of chromosomes
sorry 23 chromosomes and the diploid
number is 46 46 chromosomes so once
we've formed ours I go we now have DNA
from the mother and the father
what can then happen is I'm just going
to redraw this is the cell starts to
divide so it starts to double and double
and double it does this through the
process of mitosis so we start off with
one cell then we'll have 2 then 4 then 8
and so on it keeps on dividing and
dividing and developing and developing
so we get more and more and more cells
in this early Delap a developmental
stage it's called an embryo so embryo is
just the name for this developing ball
of cells after we've had fertilization
so a quick recap gametes means sex cells
male sex cell is sperm cell female sex
cell is egg cell they are haploid which
means they have half the number of
chromosomes so when they join together
they form a zygote with the full diploid
number of chromosomes they're fusing
together of these two things it's called
fertilization and once the zygotes being
formed the cell divides by mitosis to
form an embryo and this will go on and
form a fetus and
and a baby thank you